parked on top of a boulder that's what
court records say nfl star marshawn
lynch took responsibility for in this
crash he ended up with a parking ticket
it's video you're seeing first right
from our eight news now i-team good
evening to you i'm brian loftis i'm
denise valdez now this isn't marshawn
lynch's most recent incident from
earlier this month as the i-team first
reported back in february lynch left the
scene of a crash later owning up to it
and paying a fine the i-team's david
charns broke this story he's live at the
crash site to show us what exactly
happened david
in that crash happened right here police
say lynch was coming down tropicana here
he hit a curb traveled 50 feet and his
car ended up on that rock
the driver was described as a black male
called mid-30s it's nearly four o'clock
in the morning and las vegas metro
police are searching for the driver of
this white lamborghini
we now know marshawn lynch was the
driver of the car stuck here in some
landscaping near tropicana in durango
[Music]
yep okay
you're saying you were driving yep
where's your cousin
at home officers speak with a man at the
crash site who says he's the driver
we're blurring his face because officers
will later determine he wasn't driving
the police report the i-team obtained
says lynch who was the driver got out of
the car and attempted to remove the
vehicle from the landscaping area
according to the report he told police
he was unfamiliar with the neighborhood
missed a turn and lost control police
estimate the car hit a curb traveled 50
feet before coming to a rest on this
boulder the report says a van then
arrived and picked lynch up who got
picked up in the van
no i came in the van
you came in the van
i thought you said you were driving this
thing police say the person they're
talking to tried to take the blame it's
hard to keep your story straight when
you're lying
before anybody got here officers discuss
witness video before the car is towed
away talking about a quote big dude who
is no longer here that's the dude that
was driving big dude and this is the
dude
three days after the crash officers
interviewed lynch who told them he was
driving he said people began to show up
and video the area and he walked away to
avoid being recorded this ticket
obtained by the i-team shows police
cited lynch with three violations
including failure to give necessary
information at a collision scene
right now there are pieces of a white
car that remain here the court dismissed
two of those violations leaving lint
with that citation for basically parking
in a prohibited spot that's basically a
parking ticket now in that separate
incident just a couple weeks ago police
did arrest lynch on that charge of
suspicion of dui he's due in court for
that in december we're live near
tropicana and durango i'm david charns 8
news now
lynch's attorney sending us a statement
when david first reported on the crash
last week they say this is a non-story
mark shawn addressed this matter many
months ago and was found responsible for
a parking violation